ternes et laurence de charette à mon
avis ce que vous expliquez souligne à
quel point ce hashtag finalement est il
approprié ou en tout cas il est
réducteur il est vexatoire et
confiscatoires d'abord évidemment la
réalité les chiffres existent ailleurs
la d1 on l'a encore souligné donc dans
le figaro aujourd'hui c'est à dire une
femme sur deux a déjà été confortées
le phénomène de société il existe
maintenant la question c'est est-ce que
ce hashtag c'est la bonne façon de
lutter à mon avis il est vexatoire pour
les hommes évidemment mais pour les
femmes également pour fils catoire
d'ailleurs là la personne qui la lui
avoir comme des victimes des victimes
par destination et de façon un peu
obligatoire et systématique et c'est
assez infantilisant comme comme
d'ailleurs la personne qui a lancé ce
hashtag dit elle même bon je sais que
c'est pas très élégant gelé lancé comme
ça et donc il est d'ailleurs les
américains se sont contentés de moi
aussi peut-être que moi aussi serait
mieux que balances ton port est qu un
torrent en qu'un déversement de
dénonciations anonymes qui sont
confiscatoire à mon avis parce que ce
n'est pas la place et ça ne nous prive
du vrai débat qui se joue plus là où
vous dites c'est à dire le vrai débat
c'est la formation des policiers qui
doivent entendre ce genre de plainte
c'est les vraies mesures etc
donc on reste à côté de l'efficacité
mais à mon avis il ya une autre chose
c'est qu'on est prêt dans un piège de
guerre des sexes et surtout de entre
islamisme et puritanisme
dans les rapports dans les rapports
amoureux ou affectif en tout cas dans
les rapports hommes femmes
on est prisonnier de cette espèce de
bulle est alors qu'alain française
auparavant jusqu'il ya pas si longtemps
on savait en sortir